we have this news story that I think
plays into this Bud Light Brewery is
laying off hundreds of U.S workers well
I'm kind of sad for these people but at
the same time if you've been working at
Bud Light where over the past four
months this controversy has been going
on you had to know this was coming not
only that but several bottling plants
had already laid off hundreds of people
so y'all should look if you work for Bud
Light I would only say I am personally I
would be surprised if you were not
trying to find another job because they
are firing people but this is a sign
that the Old Guard and The Gatekeepers
are failing they are losing out get what
go broke and we're starting to see the
inverse
with sound of freedom for instance there
is an inverse to get woke go broke
starting to emerge and that is don't be
woke make money or however you'd phrase
it I don't know someone come up with
something catchier stay based get laced
get paid yeah uh yeah something like
we'll let the chat take care guys think
of something that's the inverse of this
because
this is this is what we're seeing now we
were just talking about you know Donald
Trump is getting indicted and I was
saying this earlier how do you people
like what do we do how do we win we're
watching this corruption I'm like
they're going the wrong route going this
procedural procedural route to try and
win a culture war is a losing battle and
and we should all know this because it's
what Republicans were doing in 2016.
Democrats were going to the media
they're going to TV they were lying
cheating and stealing they were pushing
false narratives Russia gate Etc to
shape the minds of the of individuals in
this country they controlled
institutions they were censoring
information on media they knew culture
comes first then politics
now what you have you have the Biden doj
protecting uh Hunter Biden with this
with this insane plea agreement they
tried giving him indicting Donald Trump
again and we got uh SBF getting his
charges dropped not all of them but how
convenient you give Democrats money you
don't go to jail I guess but I don't
think that's going to play very well
because if the influence that is
generated in culture is coming from the
likes of Angel Studios if the products
they're buying are no longer Bud Light
if they're not watching Fox News even or
CNN anymore they're coming to other
places yeah it's not like they just
stopped right exactly going somewhere
else exactly and that means eventually
Democrats aren't gonna be able to pull
this stuff off they're going to slowly
start losing political power because
they're trying to win by writing laws or
or utilizing government which I've been
saying a long time doesn't work
Republicans keep trying to do that
doesn't work great example you've got on
the books laws preventing adults from
engaging in lascivious acts with
children these laws have been on the
books for ever West Virginia for
instance has it plain as day yet the
police allow children to be part of lewd
and lascivious shows at adult venues
child drag performances all ages drag
shows that are explicit because the law
has to be enforced the police won't
enforce it though because of the culture
because we're at a point where we were
where you have these uh you have this
show where it said it's not going to
lick itself and there's kids there and
the cops go I'm not getting involved in
this even though it is illegal
discernably codified the cops won't do
anything about it because the culture is
fractured and there's no clear winner
the police are only going to do what
they think the majority would support
if sound of freedom is winning if Angel
Studios is winning if shows like ours if
cast brew coffee is winning if Bud Light
is failing eventually people are going
to say I'm here to be on The Winning
Side law enforcement's going to come out
and be like we're going to go arrest the
person breaking the law it's illegal for
women unmarried women to skydive in
Florida on Sunday
is a cop going to arrest a woman who
skydives on Sunday of course not why
it's illegal because because the law
actually doesn't matter what matters
what police are willing to enforce
so if we win the culture War
then the police are going to enforce
what the people want enforced
no I think it's true I mean the
part of government is the consent of the
people right so if you disagree with law
not only can you fight it but also your
town can start to say like this doesn't
make sense I mean there are all kinds of
old laws on the books the the skydiving
in Florida one might be an example of of
things that we would not allow or accept
I believe there's a town in Connecticut
where your husband's allowed to uh um
beat his wife on the town hall steps
during the day and that never got
repealed it's just there now if this
happened we would all be appalled like
we know some things are wrong and I
can't say why that one was on the books
ever but uh so much of what we do is
just
choosing to say like I'm not going to
give into this anymore and again I think
it's important to go back to the fact
that for a long time you know you'd get
these things companies doing something
you didn't agree with but there were no
Alternatives right like I remember uh I
can't even remember like if you wanted
to boycott uh a shoe company well that
shoe company is also owned by this
company that's also doing this and like
we saw this a little bit with uh Bud
Light that you know some people were
like well I'll buy this one it actually
is all under the Anheuser-Busch
umbrella so maybe we give credit to the
internet here for being active and
alerting to people to sort of the
network of companies but uh it is really
interesting to see people actively
seeking out change and reviewing like
what they're being told to do and saying
I don't want to anymore I think it
happens it doesn't happen it wants to
it'll happen like probably like a seven
year lag you make a movie that changes
like a nine-year-old's mind and then
when they're 16 that's when the power
begins to shift yes absolutely you guys
see that with your own kids well yeah
totally and that's the reason that we
started this is because we could see
um that this was a long game right like
the way that we were going to actually
change
the world for our children for their
children was by not not by going and
coming here to DC and lobbying and and
fighting over red and blue politics but
it was just
in our home yeah with our kids telling
really great stories that help them
understand true principles when The Dark
Knight Rises came out I had I was at
CPAC that year or something around there
and I remember sitting on this panel
discussion and them saying you know if
you're conservative and you want your
children who are interested in politics
to make a difference you actually
shouldn't send them to you see you
should send them to Hollywood and I wish
I could give credit to whoever said that
I'd forgotten the panelist's name at
this point but it's interesting because
they're basically making the point 10
years ago and you guys said Angel was
founded in 2013 that you guys ultimately
proved which is like if you want to
redirect culture you need people who
have those values in a position to make
that content I mean it's we know a lot
of people who are creative and who have
ideas but I don't remember who was on
the show talking about the the
infrastructure Behind movie production
like all all the things you need to rent
and the film equipment like there has to
be stepping stones to build this and
ultimately you guys have proven
redirecting the energy and Steve Jobs
says that the most powerful person in
the world is a storyteller that he's
famous for that statement and you can
see this with sound of Freedom Alejandro
Monteverde goes and Mexican guy
grew up was affected by cartels
his dad was and his brother were
murdered murdered by a cartel and he
builds this movie in this story
to help unite and to fight this issue
and Neil was just telling me last night
that some Bill and what state was it I
think it was Wisconsin Wisconsin or
something like a local legislator put up
a bill that's called the sound of
Freedom Bill and they're changing laws
because of this film
there was a wow there was a
um uh law enforcement officer down in
Texas who after watching the film
started classes in their community and
they're teaching teenage girls what
signs to look for how pedophiles attack
through through social media those
classes are happening all over the last
churches right-wing extremism
protect your family yeah
um
crazy stuff they showed it at Congress I
think sound of Freedom yesterday uh
Tuesday night Tuesday nights Donald
Trump's made a comment that he wants to
give traffickers the death penalty uh
women as well as men I wonder I mean
it's outstandard's idea yeah I'm not I
was like geez why does he keep jumping
to the death camera
I don't want to derail if you guys don't
want to talk about it I mean I I uh here
look traffickers people that rape kids
and sell them probably deserve death
but the death penalty I think the
statistics are they get it wrong like
four percent of the time like too much
four out of 100 people are innocent and
so it's not a practical solution in my
opinion that's my opinion I I don't I
don't like I I believe they deserve it
but if you PR can't practically make
that happen without like if you were if
you were trying to protect a kid who is
about to be attacked by someone use
whatever Force you can to save the life
of that child from the person committing
the crime right yep if we've captured
someone and Kamala Harris walks up to me
and says see that guy over there he
deserves death I'm gonna be like I don't
trust you lady I mean that guy may be
evil for sure but yeah man I'm not going
to sign off on Kamala Harris's request I
know she's the worst example I can think
of you know when it comes to who would
be Advocate right but yeah but once the
power is there it's gonna be the worst
person right yeah granted I am grateful
that Trump is entering the discussion it
shows how powerful this movie has been
that Donald Trump is entering that
discussion and participating and he had
his own screening right yeah but I mean
I we've got you wouldn't believe like
it's not just Republicans that are
asking for screeners of this movie
like everybody oh I'm asking for a
screen no look look uh
there are leftist Publications that are
saying Q Anon and stuff the guardian did
it but the critic the corporate press
critic reviews are still what like 75 or
yeah I think it's down to 70 now it
slowly gets chipped away out but
um but the but there are people on both
sides of the aisle that are very
powerful all and state leaders all over
the world like asking
should see this I I for example tomorrow
we're flying to El Salvador yeah and we
are meeting with Kelly's
premiere of the film but oh that's
fantastic he's public I can say that one
but there there are who else
you would be amazed and and I'm hoping
that some of them when they watch it
because they're they're watching it
we're talking not that they're going to
be on this uh live stream but if they
are or somebody who is uh we are hoping
that one of them will come out speak up
speak up like just just stop this
Ridiculousness everybody who's seen this
movie knows it has nothing to do with
politics and has nothing to do with
conspiracy theories to be the most
bipartisan issue passing child
trafficking it's just a true story but
that's what I keep saying law order
svu's on the on the air for 20 some odd
years I think it's still on the air
right it's it's a very very popular show
about law enforcement trying to protect
victims of sexual abuse you guys
acquired a movie and distributed and
they're so desperate to attack it it's
insane yeah but I I think I think you're
hitting a point here and Russell Brand
when he covered sound of Freedom he
covers this point I think there's like I
I I'm just racking my mind why on Earth
is everybody attack like is the left
attacking this so hard specifically the
left and I I came up with four theories
uh the first one is Russell Brands which
I didn't come up with he came up with he
just said this is a model coming out of
left field it's completely bypassing all
the Hollywood Gatekeepers they hate it
and they hate it so much that they hate
this model and the fact they can't
control it because they have their
oligopoly yeah that they would rather
attack the model with these conspiracy
theories and just forget about the fact
that the message number two there's
groups of people who are so partisan
that when the dog whistles come out they
just say uh my team's on this side so
therefore I can't watch it there's
cognitive dissonance where they're not
weighing this is millions of kids being
trafficked versus my partisan politics
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time